in the company of israeli President
Shimon Peres and Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu the Pope's wreath was laid at
the tomb of Tara Hansel one of the
fathers of the modern State of Israel
the pontiff's words reflected the
gesture the party católica vh elemental
intention as Catholics we have deep
respect for our Hebrew roots and we want
to understand them confio Conan vostro
Yuto kyonki departe right I hope the
Jews in this blessed land also develop
an interest in our faith respect ours as
we do theirs I think Wes Tutera benedita
in cui si place my greatest hope in the
youth especially Natalie Giovanni
generous urine it was then on to the
western wall where the Pope placed a
piece of paper in a crack between the
stones
earlier in the day he attended a
ceremony at Yad Vashem Holocaust
Memorial in Jerusalem here too he was
accompanied by Israel's heads of state
and government he spoke of the horrors
of the Holocaust describing it as an
unfathomable abyss following the
ceremony he met six survivors my sous la
ghetto gougou still if jonathan ben
velba avid Eliezer vivado the Pope
started the final day of his Middle East
tour on Temple Mount where he met the
Grand Mufti of Jerusalem in keeping with
Islamic customs he removed his shoes
before entering the mosque later he made
an unplanned stop at the memorial for
victims of terror where he prayed for
the Israelis killed in the violence in
the Middle East Pope Francis leaves the
Holy Land with a clear message for peace
in the hope that it will not fall on
deaf ears